ein komplett veganes Fast Food
Restaurant was vor 5 Jahren eigentlich
noch komplett gegensätzlich war es heute
Realität in Köln hat ein neuer Laden
aufgemacht bei dem genau das möglich
sein soll und den gucken wir uns jetzt
mal an Freunde herzlich willkommen zum
heutigen Video entschuldigen falls ich
ein bisschen verklatscht bin ich war
gestern Abend noch unterwegs aber das
ist kein Hindernis sondern ein Grund
unser heutiges Restaurant zu testen wir
gehen heute in die wiegen Junk Food bar
was machen die veganes Fast Food aber
von A bis Z angeblich so ist das Konzept
soll man dort ohne Verzicht einfach
alles essen können was man vielleicht
sonst als um Niveau aus dem fast
food-mark kennt also Wings Burger Pommes
offensichtlich einfach alles im warm es
gibt was auch immer es gibt sogar
Rippchen so also ich bin wirklich mehr
als gespannt das ganze auszutesten und
umso gespannter stimmen mich die
Bewertung ich habe hier nämlich gerade
mal Recherche gestartet 3,8 Sterne von 5
bei Google was wirklich ja nicht
besonders gut ist also ich glaube das
sind dann eher so die Leute die so
bisschen sind die dann dafür sorgen dass
es so eine Bewertung gibt die erste
Bewertung ist aber direkt Burger waren
gut bisschen teurer Drops dafür dass das
Restaurant nur Kartenzahlung akzeptiert
und kein gedrucktes Menü hat okay wir
gehen einfach mal auf die neuesten
Bewertung mittelmäßig und teuer 92 € für
vier Personen für kleine Portionen und
kalte Woche ist zwei Sterne Bewertung
was für ein cooler Laden das Essen
schmeckt sowohl mir nicht vegan als auch
mein veganen Freunden fünf Sterne sehr
nette Chefin super leckeres veganes
Essen und tolle Stimmung fünf Sterne die
letzten Bewertungen scheinen allesamt
relativ positiv zu sein wir gehen auch
quasi zur Eröffnung hin deshalb dürften
wir keine Probleme mit der Wartezeit
haben aber ich bin jetzt wirklich mehr
als gespannt und habe auch ordentlich
Hunger deshalb lass uns da mal die Karte
auseinander nehmen so wir sind jetzt da
wiegen-junkut war riesiger Außenbereich
wir lassen uns mal einen Tisch geben und
dann probieren wir uns durch macht schon
was her auf den ersten Blick ne
[Musik]
also der erste Blick gerade in den Laden
rein ist auch Endstufe ich glaube wir
haben wirklich an nichts gespart ich
meine mich auch zu erinnern dass der
Laden hier schon seit eineinhalb Jahren
renoviert wurde oder so da war immer
alles abgeklebt liegen klagenfurtbar und
schon damals dachte ich mir das muss ich
testen jetzt ist es soweit jetzt kann
man endlich hingehen ich bin sehr
gespannt auf das Essen das ist ja
natürlich ein ab bevor das entscheidende
gerade bei so einem hübschen Laden fragt
man sich ja ist das Essen auch so gut
wie der Darm schön ist das kennt man ja
jetzt mittlerweile aus dem vergangenen
Jahren die Karte ist digital so hier ist
das Menü
Ronaldo Wechselgerüchte zu Dortmund
gucken wir uns das ganze mal an CIA Manu
okay als PDF ich dachte das halt gleich
so wie in Frankfurt mit diesem Fans die
aufbereiteten Fotos aber erst wieder
laden auch eine sehr sehr stylische
Karte on the Rings flying Calamaris
Springs wahrscheinlich so Calamari Ringe
sein flamboy und Shrimps hotspicy Chicks
source crunchy chipsticks child spring
crispian Mix also auf jeden Fall eine
eigene Sprache hier im verkehrball
wahrscheinlich so wie bitterballen so
ein meetball vegan Burger natürlich
Schawarma Cup Salon seafood wir müssen
eigentlich ganz quer so einmal checken
einmal Shrimps einmal beef so dass wir
alle Sachen mal abgedeckt haben okay ja
ich habe jetzt irgendwie ich bin noch so
zu verklatscht für die Karte wir
überlegen uns was wir bestellen und ihr
hört es dann einfach gleich
schwarz-weiße Raum Alter
oh mama mia geil das ist ernst krank das
krass ja hat haut ihr die frisch auf
oder ist die noch mal aufgefüllt weil
die ist ja insgesamt oben voll wir hauen
die Fische auf Urlaubsfeeling hier ne
wir trinken natürlich nicht normales
sondern gönnen uns hier eine Kokosnuss
rein liebe dich ne wirklich in unserem
alten Büro hatten wir einen Asia
Supermarkt um die Ecke da habe ich auch
immer mal wieder so eine Kokosnuss zum
Trinken geholt und ich feier das sehr
ich finde das richtig lecker und ist
auch noch mal ein riesen Unterschied ob
man so eine frische Kokosnuss trinkt
oder so ein Tetrapack Kokosnuss Wasser
das finde ich sehr lecker
schön schön ich glaube die Limette ist
für drinnen gedacht weil man kriegt
sogar Löffel noch mit aber man kann
natürlich so dieses jelly dass du da
drin ist auch noch erst der
Nachhaltigkeitsgedanke ist auch in der
Metaebene noch vorhanden
der Laden hat auf jeden Fall verstanden
wie man Sachen gut aussehen lässt der
Laden ist hübsch das Essen ist hübsch
das hier ist so für mich schon so ein
bisschen too much eigentlich so die
müssen nicht rosa und schwarz sein die
Band so ich probiere mich einfach mal
kreuz und quer durch ich sage ehrlich
wenn ich in den Burger angucke aber weiß
ich nicht so genau aber hier haben wir
zum Beispiel die spicy Wings die eine
sehr sehr hübsche Panade haben obendrauf
die Ratscher Mario die ist ja per se
glaube ich auch vegan noch so eine
Teriyaki source paar Frühlingszwiebeln
weißer schwarzer Sesam macht auf jeden
Fall rein optisch überhaupt nichts
falsch aber dran scheint auch da zu sein
ich gehe einfach direkt rein
fast der erste Byte ne und mit den
Schneidezähnen dass sowas durchzubeißen
also okay das ist krass weil es hat
wirklich die faserigkeit die auch so
chicken tenderten man merkt so dass es
nicht eins zu eins den chicken Geschmack
abbildet so im Nachgang aber
konsistenztechnisch ist das wirklich
auffällig nah dran und es schmeckt auch
krass lecker also die Panade die Soßen
sind on point dann würde ich schon
dieser erste bist hat mich gerade echt
überrascht weil das kenne ich auch noch
gar nicht von Ersatzprodukten
Grüße weil ich meine man so Fasern
Durchfall auch im Mund ja aber danach
wird es so so gefühlt so ein bisschen
weniger
also das sind nicht einfach so
irgendwelche Ersatzprodukte konzipiert
so und das wäre was heißen weil
natürlich habe ich schon mal vegane
Nuggets gegessen vegane was auch immer
aber ich hier ist das wirklich irgendwie
weißer Pfeffer das hier auch so KFC
secret so in der Panade habt ihr mir
auch so weißen Pfeffer drin geile
Schärfe Ernst gut richtig gut Alter
vegane Shrimps auch so in in shrim Form
gebacken damit da reingucken da leuchtet
so ein weißes ich möchte fast sagen
Fleisch durch ich bin gespannt wie die
den für diesen seafood Taste treffen
wahrscheinlich haben die Algen
reingehauen oder so in ihre Mischung
aber es riecht erstmal relativ neutral
wir haben schon wieder die Textur
komplett getroffen das glaube ich doch
nicht so das Gefühl wenn man so sowas
durch beißt das spielt ja auch eine
Rolle alter das ist wow das ist wirklich
so dieses
Textur das Ding ist ich habe wirklich
auch wegen der Bewertung und so habe ich
gedacht das ist vielleicht so alles so
Marketing so ne und gerade aber gar
keinen Benefit oder ist gar nicht so
wirklich krass aber das ist so von dem
Produkt her was wir bisher hatten Ernst
krass krasse ist das hat sogar teilweise
so Einfärbung guck mal lol das ist
hinter der Panade die färben das ein für
die Leute die wie ich die Panade
abmachen das schon krass bisher so rein
vom Essen her muss ich sagen es ist auf
jeden Fall eine Erfahrung wert weil es
halt einfach so überraschend echt ist
bitterballen die wiegen Junk Football
kommt aus den Niederlanden und da sind
natürlich bitterballen hoch im Kurs 6,50
€ für vier Stück ist schon eine Ansage
aber habe ich schon ein paar mal
gegessen deshalb weiß ich wie sie sein
sollten
unfassbar knusprig in auch von der
Textur her wieder eins zu eins dieses
charakteristisch cremige die cheese
source würde ich nicht cheese Ausländer
das ist so eine klassisches sandwichsoße
so die hat auch die Farbe von diesem
sandwichstoßen und schmeckt auch so okay
hatte ich viel mit Käse zu tun aber
eine unglaublich unglaubliche
geschmackstiefel das ist unglaublich gut
gewürzt und es erinnert auch an so einem
fleischigen Geschmack an diese Note die
das einfach mitbringen ja du wirst aber
trotzdem bei keinem von den Sachen
denken so ist gerade Fleisch so ne dass
das sei gesagt das sind so die letzten
fünf Prozent die fehlen so also dein
Kopf wird nicht ausgetrickst wenn du das
ist aber es ist so krass nah dran dass
du schon ins Grübeln kommst auf jeden
Fall weil du denkst so glaub jemand der
es nicht wüsste der sich etwas weniger
mit Essen beschäftigt als du den kannst
du hart damit Fohlen mit allen bis jetzt
schicken mit dem Ball und mit dem
Schwimmen da bin ich mir eigentlich fast
sicher und würde es drauf wetten ich
probiere das nicht weil das ist ein
sparerib was wir oben drauf haben sieht
auch schon so lackiert aus so ne es wäre
so schön auf dem Smoker 36 Stunden
gegart
erinnert
sowieso Formfleisch ist quasi und hier
ist halt einfach irgendwie so
Ersatzprodukt in Form gebracht das
reinschauen alles am Start was man
brauchen könnte auch wieder die ich
glaube das ist einfach der lifehack weil
es so cremig und so lecker aber halt
einfach vegan
eine Couch halbe Stunde geschmacklich
auch so mehr als ich gedacht hätte aber
du kriegst halt aus dem Rip nicht so
diesen juice raus der so einen ja so
dein Hals schmiert damit wenn du mit dem
Burger ist eigentlich dadurch wird das
Ganze ein bisschen schwierig überhaupt
nicht verkehrt ne also kann man voll
essen aber ich würde einen Sachen davor
mit so einer neuen von zehn geben das
dann so eine sieben ja die Farbe muss
nicht sein ja die Werte das Produzieren
in keinster Weise auf Ja wenn du 14 bist
und du Story brauchst ja okay
ist halt wie so ein wie so ein Halloween
Essen eher so ja das ist Blut und das
ist der Tod ich friker so ein bisschen
dieses Ekelgefühl dicker von dem
farbigen Betty
Nachos lautet Nachos ums paar einfach zu
sagen ich weiß nicht wie das heißt
wahrscheinlich heißt das Nachos extreme
Nacht schon Nacho Nation und probiere
einfach mal nur den Fleischersatz das
sieht so ein bisschen aus wie das
Incredible meat schmeckt auch probier
weil das hat schon einen sehr beefigen
Geschmack schöner Nachos als hätte ich
mir den vorbereitet ich hatte so
rausgezogen
leider geil
was ich sehr sehr wichtig finde ist dass
das Nachos aus maistortiert sind also
man schmeckt so die sind Maisgeschmack
so ich finde das ist immer
Qualitätsmerkmal weil ich weiß nicht ob
so die normalen staninabschluss die man
so im Supermarkt bekommt diese gesalzen
und so ob die auch 100% meist sind aber
die haben auf jeden Fall so ein
authentischen Geschmack alles was darauf
ist dadurch dass es so viel ist was
gemischt wird ist auch nicht so dass man
denkt ja okay das schmeckt jetzt was
verkehrt oder so sondern es ist einfach
sehr lecker also ich bin fast ein
bisschen erleichtert dass der Burger
nicht gut war weil sonst würdet ihr
denken dass ich gekauft bin oder so aber
es ist wirklich alles sehr strong
wahrscheinlich auch eine Sache die wir
in der Zukunft vermehrt sehen werden
einfach so vegane Fast Food Spots
wahrscheinlich von anderen Ketten und
wie auch immer aber es ist in jedem Fall
eine Bereicherung weil Leute die sich
vegan ernähren soll mich auch sowas
verzichten müssen und damit hat man auf
jeden Fall einen sehr würdigen Ersatz
letzte Sache wieder sehr sehr schön toll
angerichtet lila Farbe pink ist da nee
also ist auch wieder sehr hübsch es sind
Onion Rings das erste Produkt welches
per natura vegan ist dass er wenig
gespannt komplett beschissen viel Spaß
danke die machen wahrscheinlich nichts
anderes wie andere oder also die stehen
jetzt seitdem wir alles gegessen haben
schon auf dem Tisch oder ich habe ja
über alles ewig gedauert wir sind immer
noch knusprig nicht mehr so warm aber
mein Schuld ich muss sagen im positiv
überrascht muss das ganze mal ein
bisschen sortieren und mein Finales
Feedback seht ihr jetzt so im Endeffekt
haben wir jetzt zu fünft gegessen und
131 € gezahlt was über 25 Euro pro
Person sind in der Junk Food Fast Food
Welt auf jeden Fall viel so weil wenn
man irgendwie bei einer einschlägig
bekannten Kette sich ein Menü holt dann
liegt man da eigentlich unter 10 €. das
ein Getränk Beilage und Burger das ist
schon teuer es ist auf der anderen Seite
zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt wo das noch
nicht weit verbreitet ist aber auch ein
Erlebnis so wo man auch ein bisschen
mehr für zahlen würde also ich fand es
überraschend gut es ist schade dass es
nicht so ganz accessible ist und die
wesentlichen Kritikpunkte die Leute vor
mir geäußert haben dass es lange
gedauert hat dass sie irgendwie mit dem
Service unzufrieden waren kann ich aus
meiner Perspektive nicht verstehen wie
gesagt die wussten wir waren früher da
ging alles flott aber es ist natürlich
ein bisschen teuer trotzdem ich bin froh
die Erfahrung gemacht zu haben
vielleicht wollt ihr es ja auch
austesten und danke fürs zusehen bin
gespannt ob wir in der Zukunft mehr
solcher Veganer Fast Food Läden sehen